[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
our good buddy from
pro football focus senior analyst steve
palazzolo joining us on the program are
you
going to be the one who defends greg
williams in that moment steve
uh somewhat i never thought i'd be a
greg williams
defender but here's my thing with it
it's just it's not as egregious maybe as
people are saying that's my
that's my biggest takeaway from this
thing yes it's what greg williams does
he likes to put pressure
uh but i look at it the general takeaway
is while he's tanking it got called in
it's a tank job it looks completely
different from what people normally do
i really think greg williams first off
it's in his nature he would blitz his
mom if she was out there right
but he he likes to attack
at those times and it's the way he was
handling derek carr during that game
you know there was a fourth and eight
you know a few plays before where he
went all out it didn't work for him
right um but derek carr was bad against
the blitz in this game he
was over six throwing the ball down the
field against the blitz he was fidgety
in the pocket he was throwing off
balance
it essentially forced derek carr and the
raiders to execute and they did
it's risky for sure but you're putting
the pressure on them to react
quickly and when you bring that many
people you can't buy time when you look
at hail mary's the aaron rodgers won
against the
cardinals the quarterback generally has
to buy time and i think you just have to
give derek carr a ton of credit
after he was fidgety in the pocket the
whole game he stepped up he found
your job as the quarterback against the
zero blitz is to find a way to throw it
mahomes likes to retreat some guys roll
out
wilson retreats derek carr stepped up
found the one place where he could throw
the ball from the pocket and executed
and made a great play
it's just not as egregious of a play
call i think as everybody's making it
out today well here's my problem with it
steve
you can send seven or eight guys if you
want to but
my secondary has to know a couple of
things don't bite on a double move
and nobody gets behind you and
i i said i would fire greg williams just
for that
you can send your seven guys you want to
put pressure on carr
i understand it that's your style but my
secondary bit on a double move
and they had nobody over the top and
ruggs was able to beat them deep
that to me is inexcusable for a guy who
has as
many years on the job as greg williams
does i mean i would i would rather have
one more safety back i do think that
the execution it's not it's tough to put
this on lamar jackson on an island right
the cornerback not the quarterback it's
tough to put it on the corners who are
sitting on an island or marcus may on
the previous one who was on an island in
the fourth and eight he had to grab
darren waller uh but i do think that the
execution of the play
wasn't great i think it's obvious you
know you've got essentially one play to
defend
you have to not let anything get behind
you there's also
what people were calling a spy you know
somebody spying derek carr that was more
just
that guy was in man coverage and once
the raiders max protected he was just
you know he should have been an out on
blitzer and i think if he executed that
properly
the spot where derek carr was stepping
up into the pocket there's
there's a jet there and so i think the
execution of the play
while risky was a big part of it as well
do we know how good sam darnold is
what's pro football's focus
the assessment of sam darnold moving
forward i try to go back to the
preseason takes i think i said it on
this show too that we won't actually
learn a ton
about sam darnold at least statistically
he's going to come out of the season
based off their their situation and not
look that great right offensive line
still
has issues the playmakers not only did
they have question marks coming in but
they've been hurt the entire season
but you just wanted to see a throw for
throw improvement
from sam darnold and we just haven't
seen that we just have not seen
a lot of the stuff that we that he
showed at usc you know at usc he was
as a redshirt his best season was his
redshirt freshman year and he looked
like he was just
so far beyond his time throwing with
anticipation and he had that fourth
quarter magic
and so many of the things that you that
just translate
that seem to translate at the nfl level
and we're not seeing that
here decision making accuracy the
situation hasn't been great but he
hasn't been elevating
that lesser supporting cast so in year
three yeah that's a huge concern for
darnold okay but
how do you factor in a bad offensive
line when you're assessing quarterback
play
i i think there's there's a there's
enough plays to evaluate you know even
against a bad offensive line you're
still
in a clean pocket 65 percent of the time
60 of the time so
you know it's just evaluating on a throw
by throw basis and saying yes if things
are better here you'll have more of
those clean pocket opportunities
but you still have to make those plays
and if you are under pressure
justin herbert's been under pressure
like crazy this year and he's handled it
really well
and i think what you've seen from
herbert is more of a his arm talents
taking over
it's really tough for him to sustain
herbert that player under pressure
but you're at least seeing those
superstar types of glimpses you
all you just don't see enough of those i
don't think from sam
darnold and here's the here's the bottom
line with quarterbacks
i think you're either a passenger or
you're a conductor right you're either a
guy that is leading the charge that is
that is carrying a bad offensive line or
an average supporting cast
or you're a guy that needs everything to
be pristine around you so
right now darnold at best is the guy
that needs everything around him and i
think that is a big part of
the evaluation going forward do you want
to invest in a guy everything needs to
be perfect around
just to get some production out of is
there a maturation process going on with
baker mayfield that we should be aware
of
he's just it's such a roller coaster
ride and we live
in a roller coaster ride of an industry
right every monday morning we have to
react to the thing we saw the previous
day
in this year on monday mornings i have
reacted so negatively to stuff i've seen
from baker mayfield
he doesn't throw passes with touch he
doesn't want to go through his reads
he's not progressing he hates throwing
from a clean pocket
and then all of a sudden in recent weeks
he's improved in that area so i do think
there
there is an element to that the system
has been great it's really tough to
separate quarterback from system
i think the best way to do it is to hold
up pff grade
against your general production numbers
whether it's passer rating or yards per
attempt or any other number that you
want
and so far this season baker mayfield's
stats have been
better than his performance but what we
saw on sunday
what we've seen at times in recent weeks
is the things they needed to improve
upon just throwing a touch pass to
rashard higgins for that 17-yard
touchdown
fantastic he wasn't doing that earlier
in the year he was playing like brett
favre
just trying to throw 100 mile an hour
laser beams all over the field so just
that
going through his progressions a little
bit more not vacating clean pockets
some of those things have improved in
recent weeks and when you combine that
with
how the browns have helped them
systematically it bodes really well for
the browns moving forward
yeah i just don't know what i'm getting
i think they have the blueprint to beat
anybody in the afc including kansas city
on the road because they run the
football
they got a front four that can put
pressure on the quarterback i don't have
to blitz
i got some skill position guys it just
comes down to
baker mayfield it feels like and then i
look at buffalo
i don't know what to expect out of josh
allen but it feels like when he plays
well he plays
really well and you saw that last night
how
where's the improvement with josh allen
where have you seen it
yeah i called him last night one of the
streakiest quarterbacks and
bills fans aren't happy with pff because
we didn't love josh allen coming out but
he has improved
in so many areas it starts with accuracy
uh
in the short area this started last year
passes up to 20 yards you did not see
this at wyoming
from josh allen just the ability to put
the ball right on cole beasley's front
number
for catch and run opportunities those
were passing he has he was airmailing
in college so i think his footwork and
accuracy in the short area has been
fantastic and then last year
he was a disaster when trying to throw
the ball down the field and that's one
of those things that tends to fluctuate
it depends it depends
a lot on the receivers that you have and
now we're seeing the combination of
allen's improvement plus what buffalo's
built
around him right having stephon diggs
having a rookie gabriel davis having
john brown when he's healthy guys that
can stretch the field
over time you're just going to have more
opportunities to create those chunk
plays
and alan has done that so the
combination of his improvement in the
short game
and what buffalo has done to build an
incredible offense around him
i also love their play calling right we
see so many
offensive coordinators try to protect
their young quarterback
by going run run run run pass right and
just
they're in third and eight all the time
there are games where the bills this is
very belichick again
they said they did it against the
seahawks a few weeks ago we can't run
against the seahawks but we could pass
we're going to throw the ball 35 times
before our
before our running back even carries it
five times that is to the
uh to the favor of the quarterback
putting him in advantageous
situations throwing on early downs and
this started last year with the bills
they put allen in a great position to
succeed
if i look at josh allen he had six more
completions of 20 or more yards so
his total on the season is 48. that ties
him with aaron rodgers for
third most in the nfl only mahomes and
deshawn watson have completed more
down the field passes to what you were
you were saying
uh carson wentz um i thought maybe for
confidence
reasons i'd sit him down and because
what he was doing on the field was not
helping him
and i want to see what i have in jalen
hurts i don't know if you can trade
carson wentz
you know with that big ticket price
attached to him but
i this is an exploratory time if i'm the
eagles like who are we and where are we
going
and who's going to lead us here did you
see enough
like what did you assess with jalen
hurts in what we thought was mop-up time
but it became a little bit closer in
that game against green bay
yeah the eagles are just in a really
tough spot it's one of those things too
i loved the jalen hurts pick
at the time because i'm all about just
finding quarterbacks and quarterbacks
that could be
of value i'm in agreement with you i
think it might be time for just a
a breather for carson wentz and i think
ultimately
the eagles are with they're tied to him
over the next few years
unless you know they can pull off a
miracle and flip him somewhere if that's
what they decide to do
so his long-term mental health and
physical
all that stuff is like the most
important thing right now for the eagles
at the same time
you can find out what you have in jalen
hurts he's he added a little bit of a
spark
i'll use the same thing about hertz that
i've said about taysom hill about kyler
murray
when you have that rushing ability it
just brings a higher floor to your
offense
jalen hurts is not the most polished
passer he's not going to
sit through and make good reads 40 times
a game
but if you add 6 8 ten carries per game
it just raises your floor where you
don't have to be as good of a passer and
it hurts as a solid passer he can hit
open throws he showed that at alabama
showed her to oklahoma so i'm intrigued
by what i saw and i think it's gonna
look a little bit different you use them
in the design running game
i think you maybe increase your jalen
hurts value but i think ultimately the
eagles are tied
tied to wentz and they need him to get
back to where he was in 2017 and 18.
steve palazzolo pro football focus
senior analyst and
pff is revealing a new product called
pff iq for teams
and agents that use pff data in their
aid to build a team
roster management you've got free agency
coming up
uh dak prescott's leverage
coming off an injury surgery team's not
performing well
so now what happens once these two
sides get back together again are we
talking franchise are we talking
long term i think they'll figure it out
long term
the only place dak has lost leverage i
think with dallas is that they might be
picking in the top ten
and all of a sudden you know the kyle
trasks of the world and the zach wilsons
of the world have emerged
and it went from a 2qb race at 1-2 with
trevor lawrence and justin fields and
all of a sudden
mack jones too will be on the show right
yeah um you have these other guys who
are
intriguing first round talents and
dallas has the other
has that other option i think dak's
leverage is strong though because
if you look at his career he's got four
plus seasons of action i think in
two of those seasons he's looked like a
top ten quarterback two seasons he
hasn't
this year he was on his way to a third
top ten caliber season
when you have that top 10 caliber
quarterback you get him
you lock him up and you and you live
with that guy i think that's what dak
has been these last couple years so i
think the last football we've seen from
dak
is so positive whether it's in dallas or
somewhere else he's the hottest
commodity in free agency
and we've seen teams that with their
with their with when you have the
mid-tier quarterback you just don't know
what you're going to get you could have
a kirk cousins type season which is nice
right now
you could have you know a matthew
stafford type season which is
inconsistent
i think dak brings a level of
consistency that the nfl teams
are going to covet on the open market
and i know jerry needs to win now wants
to win now
and almost every owner wants to win now
but i wonder
if they sat there and all of a sudden
you did have zach wilson or kyle trask
uh trey lance like you just you know
does jerry go i could get that rookie
quarterback contract
and i could continue to fill my team
with fat contracts here
and and get out from under dak
prescott's 40 million dollars a year
do you think jerry has the patience to
be able to do that in a situation like
this
so so that's the exact discussion i
think they're going to have and the
exact thing i think
when we sit down and we've built pff iq
which is this way of helping teams kind
of make these decisions
we've realized look the rookie contract
thing is great but it's greater if you
know that quarterback is going to be
good when it's russell wilson on a
rookie contract or dak
on a rookie contract as a fourth rounder
that's one of the biggest steals in the
nfl
since 2016. if you know the guy's gonna
be good that's fine but there's inherent
risk
in a zack wilson or kyle trask mac jones
whoever it might be
because you've just you've never seen
him at the nfl level there's something
to the known
commodity in dak prescott i think
ultimately that wins out but the debate
will be
rookie your contract in this great
supporting cast compared to
the dak contract i don't think the dak
level contract is as detrimental as
people think it is
if the quarterback is good and i think
he's proven that at 40 million or
whatever that number is he will be worth
it
steve always great to talk to you we
appreciate your insights thank you
you got it thank you dan that's steve
palazzolo uh one of the
senior analysts there pro football focus